Yonsei good song for this our series
common ground
highlights people who were setting aside
partisan differences in solving problems
on Friday the Justice Department
announced the release of more than three
thousand federal inmates as a result of
the first step act now that's the
bipartisan criminal justice reform bill
that President Trump signed into law
last December
former Arizona Senator and CBS News
contributor Jeff Flake recently met with
two former colleagues that Senator Cory
Booker there on your left and Senator
Mike Lee on your right to discuss the
groundbreaking legislation so Jeff this
was a bipartisan achievement so it is
possible good morning for the first time
in over a decade
Republicans and Democrats came together
to enact common-sense reforms that are
intended to make our criminal justice
system more fair I was a proud
co-sponsor of the first-step Act which
begins to tackle our nation's mass
incarceration crisis and for those who
benefit it's nothing less than a second
chance
well it's overwhelming feeling and I'm
just glad to be free
Eric Balcom has waited 16 years for this
moment
his first breaths of freedom after being
released from federal prison in Jessup
Georgia I can't be bitter about all that
I missed I just got to be thankful and
grateful for the new members that I can
make new memories with his family
including his daughter Terrica
ironically she's a corrections officer
in Florida
this would be our I'm their Balcom
reunites with his mother who's suffering
from dementia I just have to try to make
the best out of time she had left in
2003 when he was 29 years old
Eric Balcom was sentenced to life in
prison the crime selling 93.2 grams of
crack when they say life is like
somebody could have committed a murder
in 2003 and be home before I live
Malcolm had prior offenses including
violent ones but in prison he said he
rehabilitated himself take
more than 60 courses working and even
serving as a suicide companion he's free
because of the first step act a law that
reverses the harsh sentencing of the war
on drugs era of the 1980s and 90s this
is a cancer this problem is a cancer on
the soul of our country Democratic New
Jersey senator Cory Booker and
Republican Utah Senator Mike Lee spent
months negotiating the bipartisan bill
senator Lee you're a conservative
Senator from a conservative state Utah
also a former prosecutor some would say
an unlikely champion of criminal justice
reform why are you interested in this
issue interested in this not in spite of
but because of the fact that I'm a
conservative and a former prosecutor as
a former prosecutor I saw a number of
abuses of federal law I saw a young man
named Weldon Angelo's get sentenced to
55 years in prison for selling three
dime bags of pot over a 72 hour period
it's just wrong the judge sentencing him
at the time said this is wrong and only
Congress can fix this problem senator
Booker take us behind the scenes to the
negotiations well first of all I just
want to say that relationships matter
sometimes they surprise you like the
fact that I'm sitting next to a guy from
Utah not the most diverse State for him
to have a sincere concern that we have
more african-americans under criminal
supervision than all the slaves in 1850
and understand the racial dynamics here
so he and I had a real friendship and it
made for a good foundation a foundation
that Jared Kushner president Trump's
senior adviser and son-in-law built upon
Jared was a solid ally and one without
whom we probably couldn't have gotten
this past was there a moment when you
thought it might all fall apart in the
midst of the Cavanaugh hearings would
you know how hardening that was along
partisan lines I still remember getting
on the phone with Jared and he and I
being at an impasse and me being you
know angry and having my back up and
ready to upend tables over a provision
of the bill and Jared saying okay well
let's let's conference in Lindsey Graham
and this is at a moment where people on
my side of the aisle were not quite
happy with Lindsey Graham to put it
mildly and I still remember Lindsay
getting on the phone and being very hard
at Jared's
we can't do this without Cory we need to
keep this coalition together what can
you say to people like Eric others who
have been released under this program I
mean there is an anguish in these come
in my community's anguish in
african-american communities you know
ninety percent of the people being
liberated right now are African
Americans we live in a nation where our
criminal justice system is still deeply
biased against low-income people against
minorities and this was a step I just
want to tell you that I'm sorry
a step that gave Eric Balcom the
opportunity to finally apologize to his
son for Balcom it's just another step on
the long road to redemption boy sadly
Eric balconies mother passed away just a
few weeks ago he's obviously in pain but
grateful to have had time with his mom
as a free man yeah you know for decades
there's been talk about prison reform
what was different this time at the
federal level and also is there any
chance that states get on board because
most prisoners are in fact in State
Penitentiary's you know the interesting
thing is some of the states have moved
ahead and that provided a lot of impetus
for the federal government to move ahead
Texas in particular several years ago a
lot of people came together for very
different reasons some didn't want to
build more prisons they were building
two or three a year some wanted to have
you know less recidivism and to use you
know the faith community wanted to get
involved for whatever reason they all
came together eight years later they've
closed a couple of prisons recidivism is
down the crime rate is down and so at
the federal level we looked at that and
thought it works yeah so that some of
the states have moved to head gratefully
but I can't tell you what a partisan
environment we were in in December yes
and still for the Congress to come
together on an issue like this so
something that's a very powerful
reporting senator so many issues that we
need
need that we need to follow suit on
really all right wonderful